today the former racing driver close
needs fitz will be testing audi's
revamped luxury sedan the a8
meets with praises the a8 saying it's
the ultimate in luxury audi says that a
wealth of technological innovations
enable this car to do everything better
than its predecessor
time for a short history lesson audi
introduced its v8 in 1988 but in terms
of roominess and comfort it couldn't
compete with bmw 7 series or mercedes s
series
six years later the first a8 came out
with the world's first aluminum chassis
in a serially produced luxury class
vehicle
the a8 got air suspension in 2002 the
increase in comfort helped audi to edge
out bmw 7 series and number of vehicles
registered in their class where it was
second only to mercedes s series
at the end of 2011 the newest generation
of a8s was launched with a facelift
there is even a 12 cylinder engine model
conceived for the russian and chinese
markets audi has focused a lot of
attention on developing the headlight
system
veronica starringer of audi explains the
a8s automatic bright lights function
the high beams aren't operated manually
she says
instead they are electronically
controlled
individual led elements turn on or off
sequentially to automatically protect
the eyes of oncoming drivers
the blinkers have changed too
a panel of leds light up the sequence to
point in the turning direction
we tested the new luxury sedan in the
sporty s8 version
with 4 liters of engine displacement the
8 cylinder gasoline engine produces 382
kilowatts and a whopping maximum torque
of 650 newton meters
the s8 rockets from 0 to 100 kilometers
an hour in just 4.1 seconds maximum
speed is 250 kilometers an hour
the manufacturer rates the car's fuel
consumption at 9.6 liters per 100
kilometers but that demands skillfully
restrained driving
cylinder on demand contributes to fuel
thrift if power needs are low the engine
uses only four of its eight cylinders
the s8 chassis is 10 centimeters lower
than in the normal a8
is impressed that the a8's big engine is
so quiet at any speed
the interior is luxurious materials and
workmanship are lavish with the controls
conveniently arranged
continues
the variety of materials adds to the
interior's deluxe feel
the broad central console stands out and
clearly separates the driver from the
front seat passenger
an eight-speed tiptronic automatically
controls the s8 transmission
the leather seats are electronically
adjusted to fit the needs and
preferences of driver and passengers
needs fit sums up the audi s8 is a very
sporty luxury sedan he has no complaints
about the engine's power the chassis or
the brakes he says he's tempted to take
the s8 under the racetrack for a lap
everything is so top-notch except the
price which could be a little lower
the s8 base price was 114 700 euros in
germany making it exactly 40 000 euros
more expensive than the basic a8 model
but it still cost 35 000 euros less than
the sporty amg mercedes s-class
kia plans to introduce its first fully
electric car to the market in the second
half of 2014.
the sole ev will fundamentally resemble
its gasoline-powered sibling but it will
have its own design
its range between charges will be 200
kilometers and an 81 kilowatt engine
with 285 newton meters of torque will
make it fun to drive
renewable energy is on a roll in the
auto industry one of the pioneers is
sean with its project seat also
the manufacturer has mounted 53 000
solar panels on the roof of its monterey
plant
that's the equivalent of forty football
fields and means avoiding seven thousand
tons of carbon dioxide emissions
mercedes recently brought out a new
mid-range coupe sedan
the cla 200 is large and sporty like its
big brother the cls a four-door coupe
our test driver matas kurat took a
closer look at the cla 200.
mata says mercedes always calls the cla
a mid-range coupe sedan but it actually
builds on daimler's compact series the
a-class matas is going to see how well
it fits the mid-range category
the car's big grill has mean looking
headlights and large air intakes
graceful lines flow together everywhere
underscoring the car's dynamism
nothing here seems out of place
the streamlined rear has a dual exhaust
and a well concealed rear view camera
but inside our tester finds one
incongruent detail
he likes the dashboard and all the
instruments the language of shape the
vents the materials used are all lovely
but the display in the middle of the
dash for the radio entertainment system
and navigation sticks out like a sore
thumb montes is sure this could have
been better integrated
the interior design is very reminiscent
of mercedes sls
the steering wheel speedometer and
decorative elements all have a sporty
feel
the design is clearly structured except
for the myriad buttons on the curvy
central console
it's a luxurious ride up front but what
about the back seats
mata says the back seat shows that the
car is based on the a-class and the
coupe like roof line means the back
seats aren't comfortable for tall
passengers
at least there's lots of room for
luggage mata says the cla's 470 liter
trunk really is mid-range level it's
only five liters smaller than the
c-class
for more sportiness in the cla you can
spend an extra two thousand euros for
the speed shift transmission our test
driver is pleased overall with the cla
the cla's handling really pleases mantis
who says the car hugs the road and you
don't even notice that it's a
front-wheel drive that's because the
power steering reduces the typical
front-wheel drive feel
our test car's 115 kilowatts of power
accelerated to a maximum of 230
kilometers an hour its eco start stop
automatic optimizes fuel consumption in
city traffic
mata's current summary
mercedes has really done a good job of
avoiding confusing the cla and the
c-class the clas and c have smaller
engines those with the same names are
simply a bit less powerful except for
the c200cdi and the cla200cdi
which have the same push the two series
are geared to different people the
c-class is the sensible car the more
versatile one but also a little more
expensive the difference in price is
between two thousand and five thousand
euros depending on the engine size the
cla in contrast is more for the
lifestyle oriented buyer who plans to
drive alone they are air aligned affairs
with a
our the foreign variant of our test car
with a seven-speed automatic
transmission costs 37 890 euros in
germany the basic model is available for
6 000 euros less
sorry
opel's black widow
in the late 1960s it spread fear and on
german race tracks
now it's back
it was a resurrected opal record and
racing gear black broad and brawny opal
and racing fans may remember the
legendary car from more than 40 years
ago here the replica heads out for its
first drive
the record see was the epitome of middle
class life white bread on wheels and
suddenly the ordinary family car was
leaving porsches in the dust and racing
greats like eric bitter and a young
nikki lauda were in the driver's seat
the recreated black widow takes to the
asphalt of the handling course at opel's
dudenhoffen test center
the modified engine has to be run in
before it'll show what it can do
opal's first post-war racing car was
built in russell's heim in 1967 without
gm's approval
it was a creation of opal designer
anatoly lapine
after a few successes on the track the
black widow mysteriously vanished
now opal classic's jens cooper has built
a replica of the original
he says the first step was getting
photos from anatoly lapine himself
hardly any other information was
available not from the archive nor
private sources but lapine provided a
flood of information
lapine personally drew up the rear axle
design on a meals on wheels menu
opal's classics department gave the
go-ahead and yens found a 1966 opel
record to serve as the basis
many of the black widows components had
been custom made and to make the replica
as true to the original as possible they
had to be made again the project took
three years
in 1967 a 180 horsepower engine and a
900 kilo car produced a sensational
power to weight ratio especially for a
dowdy opal sedan and for the time it
handled like a champion mag wheels and
the special rear axle design played
their part too
a counter flow head was put on the opal
four-cylinder engine to increase
performance
cooper explains that it had specially
cast manifolds and dual webber two
barrel carburetors and a special
camshaft to give it more oomph
with a special intake manifold it had
double the performance of a normal
record
it would be hard to tell the replica
from the original if the original black
widow could be found
team leader kirk bagman a former opel
dealer and racing legend in his own
right was looking after the car during
the time nikki lauda was driving it
he remembers the car was in the
courtyard without its engine
they had been on the formula 5 circuit
in europe and suddenly the car vanished
to this day nobody knows if it was
stolen or what exactly happened to it
the black widow's mysterious
disappearance makes its resurrection all
the more dramatic now its fans are
hoping the replica will be making the
rounds at classic car shows and giving
its contemporaries a run for their money
just like the original once did
you